Okay.
So thank you,
Michelle for joining us.
I'm ed through our,
for those of you don't know me,
I'm a business manager in g class.
Um,
Michelle is the CEO of peanut and she's also the founder and it's a basically a
Tinder style dating apps for mums to meet other mothers.
Um,
she,
the,
the APP launched in Fed visio and has had amazing traction so it's been picked
up in the press a lot.
So you might've seen her mentioned there.
Um,
and we want it to get,
take this opportunity for her to come in because I know a lot of Googlers sort
of talk about starting their own thing or starting something outside of work.
And sometimes the inertia of just being in your day job can stop that.
So someone who's actually gone from working for other people to working for
herself,
it's quite an interesting journey.
So,
um,
Michelle also launched peanut,
uh,
on android and October.
Yeah.
So finally we,
uh,
we can claim fame to it too as well,
which is amazing.
So I'm going to do a few questions,
but really,
please come.
Please have like your own questions prepared.
We'll have loads of time at the end for,
um,
for your questions as well.
Um,
so,
um,
I remember distinctly when you first kind of talked to us about the ideas,
I know Michelle outside of this particular thing,
um,
we were at a,
uh,
at a wedding and she had a phone and a deck on a phone and it was like,
this is my idea for,
um,
uh,
for an app and what it was going to be like.
And she,
I remember at that point she was kind of passing the phone around a table and a
lot of people were like,
this is amazing.
And equally a lot of people were like,
isn't this like Mum's net?
And like really like challenging about the idea?
Um,
yeah.
So can you talk a little bit about where the idea came from?
Yeah.
And then how you kind of got to that first investor meeting and kind of like the
challenges and the People's reactions to that?
Yeah.
So,
um,
I started life actually as a corporate lawyer way back when and that was my kind
of am starting point.
I still a lot of m and a and I went to work in house for a biotech company,
which was again very,
very different and not very many all.
Um,
and one of the lawyers that I used to work for called me and said,
you should go meet this guy.
He's a new client of mine.
Um,
I,
he needs someone to go and work with them.
I think you'd be great.
I think you'll love it.
It's a dating website.
I was like,
not really,
and this was back in 2010 and dating was definitely not what it is now.
And there was definitely a feeling of like dating,
not sure,
maybe something your parents did when they got divorced or it just wasn't like
it is today.
Um,
and tech definitely wasn't kind of in London.
It definitely didn't have the same feel and an excitement and buzz that it does
now.
Um,
and I went to meet the founder who was a young guy who was,
um,
unusual and um,
it was interesting.
I'd never really understood it as a business.
And what I mostly couldn't understand is that when they were 56 million people
using this product,
I'd never heard of called Badu.
Um,
yeah.
And um,
I met a few more people.
It was very exciting.
It was in some crazy rundown office in Soho.
And um,
I decided I would do it.
So I became the lawyer there.
Um,
I'm very nosy.
I all sorts of questions under the guise of being the lawyer you're allowed.
Um,
and particularly was fascinated by it was making money.
I wanted to understand how people were using the product,
what the journey was,
why they would pay for certain things.
Um,
and then I was kind of there for the evolution from web to mobile.
So this was all back like web.
I think the most adventurous we had was well,
um,
and it was kind of that transition and that was exciting.
I'm really understanding why people's behavior was different,
why people were spending differently,
how long they spent on web versus mobile,
all of those different,
um,
kind of vantage points that I'd never really seen of the business before.
Um,
and it kind of came to the evolution of Tinder.
Tinder came out and I remember my girlfriend's in the states talking about it
and me being like,
what is it?
Um,
and it was a gray screen and I was desperate to see and desperate to understand.
And,
um,
that was really the kind of starting point of looking more,
less about legal,
um,
and more about kind of being involved in the business.
Um,
I started working alongside Andre,
has his kind of right hand,
um,
and became deputy CEO at Purdue and as part of that was involved in a bumble,
which I'm very proud of and was very exciting.
Um,
and I suppose it was that whole journey and that was kind of over the course of
five years,
wrapped up in 30 seconds,
um,
that I,
decided that I really wanted to do something that,
a product that I would use.
I wasn't dating,
um,
in my personal life.
Um,
and I really had had this experience when I became a mother that I didn't really
have any girlfriends who had babies.
And I really wanted to just take all of the kind of learnings that I had about
connectivity and apply it to women.
I also was really frustrated,
um,
by the products that were out there for mothers.
Everything changed.
You go from using,
whether it is snapchat at the time,
which was really,
really buzzing or Insta or Pinterest or delivery or any of these amazing or Uber
or any of these,
like very slick,
cool products.
And then you become a mom.
And it was like,
well,
where's my thing?
Um,
and everything felt like it was very much aimed at babies,
kids and not aimed at me as a woman.
Um,
and so I decided I would do it.
So I,
um,
left Purdue in January last year and it was absolutely terrifying.
I loved my job and I love what I did and I was very proud of everything that I
did with [inaudible],
with bumble.
Um,
and so to make that move was,
or,
you know,
I was very scared.
Um,
but I really wanted to do it and I believed in it and it wasn't just that I
wanted to do a product for me,
it's a huge business opportunity.
You know,
women are making 85% of household decisions on spend and yet there was just this
huge gap and I really wanted to,
to address it.
Um,
so I left,
did a lot of consulting,
saved a lot of money because I knew I'd have to start the build on my own and
um,
went to one of our friends' weddings and was kind of talking through it.
And one of our friends in particular who is now a very avid supporter was like,
I didn't get it.
I don't think mom's really need this.
And I was like,
how would you know,
you're not a mom,
but also,
um,
why?
And he was like,
yeah,
but this is mom.
I was like,
absolutely not.
This is something very,
very different.
Um,
and I think at that time I had had my term sheets so I just got a term sheet
from NEA.
Um,
and getting the term sheet,
it was a real whirlwind cause I don't think I really fully appreciated what that
process was.
So I'd gone from,
I probably threw naive butty I just was really ballsy and had me in a deck.
So that's all you,
how did you commission someone to do some research or did you do your research?
I had done,
I'd just gone and researched the market,
had a look at what a change,
what was the size of the market,
what else was out there?
Like doing those weird competitor analysis,
speaking to women.
So many women everywhere on Facebook groups,
on,
you know,
in real life everywhere.
Asking them what they did,
what was their view.
Um,
lots and lots of that kind of qualitative research was one of the overwhelming
things that came from that was that there was just nothing on the market that
really targeted a woman who was active.
It was a modern person basically.
You seem to be like 80 from the ATS.
Yeah.
I think that the overwhelming response was we were using products are women were
using products that were there because that's all they had.
And there wasn't really anything that had kind of innovated forward.
And it was that moment for me where I was like,
why can't it be me then?
Like why can't I be the one to change it?
Um,
and that is not to do down any of the products that were out there,
you know,
mum's net babycenter,
what to expect.
All of these amazing platforms did something amazing 15 years ago,
which is they gave women a voice who are mothers and we didn't have it before.
So I would never ever knock that.
It was just,
I was looking at doing something different.
Yeah.
So you had this idea,
you have this deck.
Yeah.
How do you,
where do you go from there?
Like who are you,
who are you shopping it around to you and how do you get your first investors on
board?
And what was that process like?
Especially since there wasn't anything exactly like what you were describing on
the market and you're going to a lot of investors who I'm assuming don't
understand that particular psyche and that particular loneliness that comes from
adulthood.
So how do you kind of go through that process of convincing them that this is
something that there is a market for.
That part is challenging.
So in terms of how you identify it's very different or how I did it this time
round and how I would do it going forward.
And if I were doing it again is very different to how I did it.
You know,
I'm completely naive,
Lee and an experience layer,
which is,
I spoke to everyone.
If someone said,
I'll give you an intro.
I was like,
great,
I'll take the intro.
And I was nondiscriminatory and who I spoke to.
And I suppose the upside of that is I learned a lot.
So I learned when things,
um,
what conversations not to have.
Um,
what the difference between a late stage,
the early stage fund is.
And all,
you know,
when someone says to you,
we're at the end of our fund,
but if you can hold off until we're at the beginning of our next fund,
what does that even mean?
Like all of those things that I just work complete minefield.
Um,
and this time I have been much more kind of targeted and I want to speak to you
cause I think you understand the market or whatever it might be.
Um,
I,
I spoke to everyone and that is tough.
Yeah.
Um,
I shamelessly ask for interest to people.
Yeah.
And yeah,
that's it.
And I asked friends and friends of friends and um,
I met any eighth through,
um,
Whitney at bumble and that was the kind of starting point.
And from there anyone I spoke to,
I would always say at the end of it,
thank you so much for your time.
If you can think of anyone else that you think I should be speaking to.
And I always ended like that.
I don't think that's necessarily the right way,
by the way,
do it,
do your own research and you can be like more targeted,
targeted because it's important for you to,
it's like a marriage,
right?
You're getting into a relationship with this person.
They're going to be in your business.
So how did you approach things differently with your second round?
This is your seed funding round.
She just closed.
It was in the,
on the front page of the Times.
I don't know if anyone else saw it.
Um,
uh,
so yeah.
That's fantastic.
So congratulations on that.
So how did you approach it differently?
Did you target funds and say,
I'm going to go after you for your life because I believe that you'll understand
this market a little bit,
that
better.
It was obviously easier because before I was pre product I was kind of pre-team.
Actually Greg and I haven't at the point that I was starting to,
to investors,
Greg and I hadn't decided to work together.
He's my co founder.
Um,
and so it was very,
very early.
Um,
this time,
obviously our product is out there and we have metrics.
We have a team we can go out and it was,
you know,
it's much easier to speak to people.
And um,
I was much more kind of purposeful about who I was speaking to and why.
Um,
and so we have two joint need investors on this round and they both bring
something different that I'm really excited about.
Sweet capital who are the founders of king.com.
So candy crush,
um,
which was really exciting for me from a product perspective and their insight
and their understanding of women spending time on candy crush and all of those,
you know,
that was valuable for me and I really was excited to have them on board and the
female founder's Fund in New York obviously exciting for me to have,
um,
a kind of female VC with that kind of overview and understanding of the female
market.
So,
um,
I was very,
very specific about who we spoke to.
I'd also kept in contact with people like Greg Kraft who I'd met first time when
I was doing our pre seed.
And so when I was like,
look,
we're doing our seed,
obviously I'd built a relationship with them over a year.
So then it was easy for them to say yes,
you know?
So,
um,
I think that's how it was different.
It was definitely more,
um,
targeted.
I think probably,
um,
naivety made me a bit fearless.
It's time,
but also,
you know,
your waste a bit of,
you do waste a bit of time in that way.
And if you're doing it ever,
you can be selfish.
Your time is precious too.
And maybe it's not the right time to take that introduction.
If someone says to you,
amazing weight right now,
I'm just going to introduce you to,
it's okay to say,
actually,
can I come back to you when I'm ready for that introduction because you don't
want to waste it,
but to be like an amazing intro,
but do it at a time that suits you.
Yeah.
So you,
um,
so if I go like good back a little bit for when you first launched.
So you want to sort of make a big splash,
but I assume you don't want a bunch of people kind of downloading this app and
no one else's on there.
And I was listening to an interview with the Tinder founder and he was like,
he basically like ran from one room to the other.
I'm in a college campus and was like,
women are there.
And then he ran to the other room and was like,
get on that because men are there and he had to kind of get those first people
online before you could actually get sort of big traction.
So how did you get those,
that first kind of critical mass before you can make a big splash in the market?
Or is that how you did it or how did you kind of interact?
Um,
the idea was cause
we would launch in London,
New York simile tediously and we would seed it with some women who we knew had
existing communities,
very small.
It was really proof of concept.
Can you go and test it,
seed it to women that you know,
get,
get their feedback.
Let's see.
So rarely in that first week I think we thought we'd be doing really well if we
had like 50 people using it and we could kind of see their interaction and we
did do that and then the next day it went,
um,
and the press coverage was insane and very interested.
Um,
and so that kind of amplified.
but I still kind of was very clear on the fact that if you're building a social
product,
you have to feel exactly what you said.
Like there are people around you,
you can't open the APP and be like,
okay,
so the nearest woman is intelligence that he had that problem.
So we were very focused on it.
But,
um,
we then became very reactive.
So we would see,
um,
women using it and Dallas are women using it in la or women using it in Chicago.
And then we would do a small event or a dinner or something to let other women
know in that area.
You'll have a great user experience of use peanut here because we already have
thousands of women using it.
But it was very organic up until that.
Amazing.
So you've sort of talked about,
but you were involved in dating apps and Michelle actually named bumble.
Um,
so you've got a knack for naming thing.
and we've sort of seen this arc that you also described that dating was online
dating was very weird to begin with.
And now if you are single and you do want to meet someone,
like it's not a question you would be on a dating app.
Yeah.
So what does the arc that you're trying to sort of see with peanut?
So my observation,
and you could tell me if this is right or wrong cause that loneliness is sort of
the one of the last taboos that we talk about.
And not just for Moms,
it's like if you're married or anything,
you kind of have to have this bravado about not being alone.
Yeah.
So where do you sort of see,
like what is your overarching mission and where do you see kind of peanuts
shaping that art?
I think that,
um,
you're absolutely right,
the evolution from dating going from something slightly awkward to everyone's
doing it and my friends describing it as Michelle likes and dating Tim Michelle
Lakes and data.
Um,
I remember it so clearly and I think that there is a lot of discussion around is
tech and social media making us more lonely.
Um,
and for me it's all about how you use it.
If you're using it in a way that helps you have those in real life connections,
how could that ever be a bad thing?
Um,
so we have tools within peanut that facilitate,
um,
polling and scheduling times to meet.
So it's like having a doodle effectively but within the messaging and three
clicks and it's in your calendar.
And for me that was really important because it's about getting that face to
face.
But what's more scary kind of sitting,
looking at your phone and,
and kind of watching everyone else's life or then sending a connection to meet
someone in real life?
Well,
it's more scary just watching the world pass year.
Um,
so I think that we will see more,
there is a lot more conversation around loneliness.
I know that we have a lot of conversations about on millennials,
the loneliest generation ever in all of these things.
And I think that it's about encouraging tech or using tech to help you meet in
real life and to facilitate in real life.
Um,
and I think that the,
the taboo,
the last taboo that we need to break is actually being able to come out and say
as a 30 something,
yeah,
I'm lonely.
Or yeah,
this is tough.
And it's not everything that everyone told it told me it would be,
or um,
yes,
sometimes it's 2:00 AM and I felt like the whole world's asleep and I'm awake
feeding this baby and no one else understands me or whatever it might be.
And that kind of being able to have that contact with someone and support and
network is really important.
Do you find that that's sort of your biggest barrier to growth is that people
kind of download the APP and then they're nervous about actually contacting
other moms and do sort of see a massive difference between like you've launched
in the states obviously and how they've adopted the product very differently
from here?
Yeah,
so I think that there is a difference between the US and the UK behavior we're
in,
in the US and the UK.
Um,
culturally,
I don't know how terribly British it is to speak to people.
We don't know.
I don't think we're madly good at it versus in the states where people are
perhaps a little bit more,
um,
open to giving it a go.
Um,
and so I do think that,
um,
we can see a little bit of a difference.
Again,
it kind of depends on your stage of life as well.
If you used a dating app to meet your partner,
of course this doesn't seem like a hurdle.
What of course it would be a natural thing that you're going to use an APP like
this to meet friends.
Um,
so there were all different,
you know,
it's very personal in that way.
Um,
I think that we do see women who,
um,
use the happen and watch a bit of watching.
I'm a lurker too,
so I totally get it.
Um,
so watching before they do it.
And then I sometimes get messages from women,
what,
what can I say?
I don't know what the best message to send us or whatever it is.
Um,
and for me,
I just say anything,
say hi,
say what you're eating,
whatever.
It doesn't matter.
Um,
but it's,
that's much less scary sending that message as much less scary than spending a
week on your own without a grownup to talk to you.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So I'm going to open it up to the,
to the floor in like one question.
So keep them already.
Um,
before I do that.
So at Google,
I mean we obviously started out with the two people in a garage and one of the
sort of principles that we try to stay to true to you at least is um,
being very scrappy and like that less having less will force you to be smarter
and do better.
So you're obviously small still.
So how are you thinking?
You've got ambitious plans to peanut,
but you're still a small team.
So how are you prioritizing and how you're thinking about your next growth stage
given that constraint?
Um,
so that you kind of propel yourself in the best way possible to grow?
I think it's really,
I do believe that having little makes you scrappy cause you have no choice,
right?
You and it's,
it's do or die.
I have to go out there and I have to establish that the product is firstly
viable.
And secondly,
we've got traction.
Otherwise we have no product.
Um,
so I do,
I do believe in it.
We are a team of six,
so we're very small.
Um,
and every decision I make,
I equate to headcount.
So if I'm going to spend x on a really nice office,
for example,
and I'm not currently,
I'm squatting,
um,
but I'm,
I'm going to send x on office space,
we'll that's like two extra people in the team that could make us go,
you know,
reach that part of our roadmap three months ahead of,
of plans.
So I always equate it to,
to head count and the ability to go faster.
Um,
I cheekily asked for favors.
People have asked me for favors in the past and I've always liked helped where I
can.
So I don't think anyone should be shy to ask for favors.
They actually might be really excited to work with you.
And what's the worst they say?
No.
Okay.
No,
it's,
it's no,
it's no bother.
Um,
so I,
I shamelessly ask people and,
um,
I think what we now need to do,
we're,
we're building a new feature at the moment,
um,
which is very kind of like head down,
product focused.
Um,
and then we really have to go out and amplify it.
And that's quite scary because I have to go and let all of our existing users,
no fine,
that's not a bother.
But now it's really like kind of sharing it more widely and we have a limited
budget and we have,
you know,
a certain time to establish it in and we'll have to learn as we go.
And probably because we're a team of six,
we can be quite agile and say,
okay,
that didn't work,
scrap next.
Um,
yeah,
we do a bit of test and dump test.
It didn't work,
go next.
Um,
and um,
I think not being precious and not being too tied to your idea of,
you know,
this will work and being prepared to sit okay and on with the next,
um,
is helpful.
But I've made mistakes along the way.
Like of course we all,
we all do.
And it's,
I mean,
in hindsight at the time it's the most painful thing in the world.
You're like,
oh my God,
that was 5,000 and then it's five k that I will never waste again.
So.
Absolutely.
So I'm going to open it to floor anyone with questions?
Okay.
Sorry.
Quick question.
Two quick questions for you.
One,
founders are Casandra's are really important,
um,
because after your kind of seed funding for all of the rounds that do,
it was really important to investors.
So how did you pick your cofounder?
And the second question is,
did you find what you were looking for out of peanut?
Yup.
Um,
so Greg is my perfect opposite.
he is,
um,
brilliant,
not,
but I'm not brilliant.
Sounds awful.
Um,
confidence or shell,
but he is,
he's very focused and he is a brilliant technician and he is very logical and
I'm always thinking over here and he's thinking about kind of how we're going to
get there.
Um,
I found,
um,
Greg purely by accident.
Um,
I was speaking to a friend that we had in common and saying that I really needed
to hire,
but I couldn't hire anyone from Vudu or Bumbo.
I was under restrictive covenant and so my usual pool was out of bounds and she
said,
oh,
you should speak to Greg.
He's just left delivery.
He'll,
he'll have an idea of like the market.
And,
um,
so I was waiting for the introduction and I got really impatient.
I was taking a long time,
so I just emailed him and I was like,
so I'm waiting for this introduction from our friend.
Um,
can I pick your brains about the market and,
you know,
whatever.
And we started speaking and he was like,
actually,
I love the idea,
I'm going to do it with you.
So it was kind of fell into it and that way,
um,
he has a little girl and had to kind of understood the issues surrounding it.
Um,
and so I was very lucky in that way.
And um,
he's definitely,
you know,
probably the better half of peanut m and in terms of have I got out of peanut
what I wanted,
it is the best feeling in the wild.
When someone messages you to say,
I've just met my ex best friend on peanut or I was having a really tough time
and I can see light at the end of the tunnel because I've got a,
you know,
a drink with a girl I've met on Friday,
whatever it might be.
Um,
because that's what it's for.
Right.
And my favorite thing,
it's like a weird get off a plane,
wherever I am,
open peanuts,
see like women around hi,
speak to them psycho,
um,
just to,
to kind of see what they're doing.
And it's amazing.
I can find out like where they go to eat or where's like a kid friendly place,
whatever it is.
And it's that kind of community and hyper community.
It's amazing.
So yeah,
I'm very proud of it.
Um,
my name is Camila.
I'm super excited to have you here.
Um,
so the question is,
you're,
you're being a lawyer.
I'm,
I'm assuming you did have some exposure to technical terms and stuff in your
previous careers,
but still building an APP is very technical.
So how did you overcome,
you know,
how deep was your knowledge?
Did it have to be,
or you probably had your cofounder to help without,
basically the fear is can you actually learn all these things and do you have
to,
as a founder,
yeah,
and we,
I think most of the people in this building are on the business side.
Yeah.
And so when we talk to engineers,
there is like a little bit of a,
uh,
a disconnect.
So how do you kind of like the sort of extension of that is,
how do you like the talk,
make your preferences known so that they kind of interpret it into what is now
really a beautiful app?
Um,
I just ask questions all the time and I,
I,
I don't think I really have a shame about whether it's a stupid question or
because it would be more stupid if I pretended to know and it turns out wrong
or,
you know,
I haven't been able to express it in the right way.
Um,
I am very fortunate Greg is patient.
and I do have a brilliant team who I kind of communicate well with.
And you're right,
I was working in an industry where I have an awareness,
but,
um,
I will ask and I will,
pick and prod until I understand why we can't do something or why it's been done
in that way.
Um,
and I just think that you have to be fearless in the questions.
Actually you'll find in the same way that you feel proud about your work every
day.
The engineers are so proud of what they do.
If you ask,
they're delighted to share it with you.
Right?
Like everyone in my team of I want to know something that delighted to tell me
why.
Um,
it is,
and um,
I suppose if you were so interested in your,
you both care about what you're building,
it's natural that you will ask and they will answer and you'll,
you'll get to that point.
But I don't think you should ever be fearful of what you ask.
I think that's the question.
Yeah.
Two things.
The first one needs is a,
Eh,
because in the social network you have that effect that the more people you have
a level of law I want,
won't ask about how you picked up the very initial people to shoot it with.
Yup.
Because it's,
you know,
it's,
Eh,
it influence the trajectory.
The second thing that I wanted to ask us about funding show,
where did you go for funding and why?
Since you have a,
you can,
I guess connection if they're of,
I've seen that there are things that fly here and don't fly over there and vice
versa if you have an opinion about it.
Um,
so in terms of getting those initial users and getting nice at that initial
attraction and that really comes down to me just speaking to a lot of people and
kind of being cheeky enough to say,
so I've got this APP coming out,
can I let you know by when it's like,
we'll test it for me.
You know,
mostly people want to be involved and they want to help you and they want to
kind of test something new.
So again,
shamelessly asking people,
we do that,
will you send,
will you share it with your friends?
Were telling your friends when it's ready.
Um,
and using my friends in the states in New York to say,
okay,
can you ask your girlfriends?
So it was really that.
Um,
and I think that the more you talk about something,
I,
I've heard people say,
you know,
where things that you mustn't tell anyone your idea.
Don't tell anyone your idea until it's ready.
I just think it's bizarre because how will you ever know whether your idea is
for you or for everyone or you'll never know whether your product has a good fit
or not.
So,
um,
I spoke with Mitch Nice and bought them at a wedding.
Um,
I spray it,
I spoke to everyone about it because I wanted to hear more and I wanted to know
what people had to say about it and I wanted to understand how would use it and
why.
So that then when it came to release,
they were excited to test it for me.
Um,
I test it.
I had a group of girlfriends who I was testing colors with,
do you like this color or this color?
Do you like this logo or this logo?
Would you press this button or this person?
I mean,
it was really,
um,
like that.
So,
um,
I think if you're doing something social,
you have to find that pool of people who you want to test it with and test.
And in today's kind of environment,
you can create that group anywhere you can create it.
In a Facebook group or a,
you know,
on Twitter,
gather people,
get some people on an Instagram handle and get them to follow you.
And then,
you know,
there are so many ways that you can test like a get a social group and test it
before you have to get to the stage where you're going to build an apple or
whatever it might be.
Um,
in terms of funding and getting the right funders.
as I mentioned before,
um,
I have got the most brilliant funders and I'm so super proud of all of my
funders and they all bring something different as all a different angle.
Um,
I have some who are us and some who are UK,
so I don't have predominantly us or UK.
I have a,
a bit of a split.
Um,
I say UK,
I mean Europe actually.
Um,
so I have a bit of a split.
and I think that when finding funders,
it's really about finding the right people who understand your business.
And really this time round,
I researched so that I knew exactly what businesses they'd invested in before,
whether they were analogies to what I was trying to do or whatever it might be.
So,
um,
you know,
it's pretty dispiriting when you speak to people and they're like,
moms don't need that.
They drink coffee all day or,
um,
but I'm not showing my wife that she spends enough time on her phone or whatever
other months and stuff and I've heard it all.
Um,
and then you here you meet someone and they're brilliant and they say,
okay,
so what's the size of the market?
Okay,
so why is what you're doing different to how you're gonna monetize?
Okay.
So where do you think the barrier to entry is an all of these smart questions
cause they're not seeing it as you,
as a woman who happens to be a mother and creating a mothering out.
They're seeing it as a business and a market potential and it's finding those
gems and they are there.
And I think that we,
at the moment,
there's a lot of bad press around the funding and vcs.
And,
um,
that's probably deserved for those who deserve it.
But there are some brilliant,
brilliant minds out there and it's just about finding them and being relentless
in your search to find the right partner for you.
You found funding pre-revenue?
Yes.
Okay,
thanks.
Pre-Product play.
So what's changed for you now that you run your own business versus being CEO?
Someone else's business?
It's like Jbs to have that dream.
When you go into school and you're naked and everyone's laughing,
you don't know why and then you let down your naked.
It's like that dream every day.
Um,
it was like that at the start.
It's very scary,
you know,
there is strength in numbers.
And when,
you know,
when I was at Purdue,
um,
I really felt like I was part of something huge but a small part of something
huge.
But,
um,
there was that safety and when you're doing it on your own,
it's all on you.
And it's really scary and it's personal because,
you know,
I always cared about my job and it was a huge part of my identity,
but I care so much about peanut because I don't want to let my team down,
my investors down,
my users down,
like women down like this.
There's so many huge pressures that I just don't want to let that fall.
Um,
and so there is a huge burden of responsibility.
Similarly.
Um,
I feel that,
um,
the highs are extraordinarily high because you know,
every single ounce of when you moved that,
you know,
tiny,
tiny icon 0.2 millimeters to the left and you know that there was a real thought
process behind it and you know,
all of a sudden your conversion increases and you're like,
Huh.
And no one else knows that,
but the highest so high from that,
um,
that,
it makes it all worthwhile,
but it's extraordinarily hard work and,
um,
which it was before,
but it's a different kind of work and pressure I think.
Yeah.
Am I have a few questions.
Um,
one is the,
how did you get your roadmap and how,
um,
in terms of company growth,
what,
what do you see in the future and,
um,
how would you kind of realigned that when things change?
Um,
my second question is I guess having a startup and being so passionate about it
and um,
having a successful career that you've had,
how do you,
um,
you almost become consumed by your idea because it is,
you know,
and it's good to be because he's so passionate.
But how do you find,
keep yourself sane in terms of working hours and you know,
this,
um,
how,
how'd you do that?
I think that's one of my main questions
cause otherwise I'll forget them.
What was the first one?
So in the US,
and again,
it was around the roadmap.
So the roadmap was,
um,
I suppose it was like this very kind of broad vision of peanut has to be like
modern motherhood and that's what we want it to represent.
And,
and here are all the facets of modern motherhood that we could cover.
Okay.
I don't want that.
We don't need to be that someone else is doing that.
And really kind of boiling it down in that way.
And then thinking very specifically about
where we really felt like that the opportunity lies lay and,
and how we can kind of unpack it and get,
get through that.
Um,
and I would say that the roadmap is ever,
and sometimes we have,
uh,
an idea and we all love it,
but we know it's not a priority and it kind of gets shuffled to the back and
it's that sad kind of item and Jay are that will maybe never like come to the
forefront.
Um,
and we hope it will but probably won't,
you know,
until we kind of doubled in size.
Um,
and sometimes,
um,
it is imperative that we deal with something because it's impacting on the way
users are interacting with the product.
Um,
so I think it's just being on your toes all the time and not being wedded to it
so that you're prepared to change.
And we have an idea for,
you know,
our subsequent feature to the one we have,
but it might change.
We have to wait and see how users use our next feature first before we can
really see,
okay,
it's not going to be the right direction or maybe we'll discover something brand
new.
So I think a lot of it comes from watching like user behavior as well and your
analytics and really like being so grateful for all the amazing data where you
can kind of watch the behaviors,
um,
balance and work.
Life balance doesn't exist just in case anyone was interested.
So lie,
um,
I think it's a juggle,
right?
And some days you're amazing at juggling things and Sundays you're terrible at
juggling things and some days you're an amazing partner and sometimes you're a
horrible partner and sometimes you're amazing boss and sometimes you're the
worst and you just have to be a little bit of peace and you kind of juggle it.
Um,
but if you're going to do something that you love,
you have to be a bit obsessed by it.
I think it literally all of my friends and family or peanut.
Okay.
Um,
that's all I can talk about.
And,
um,
I think you have to be like that because it's what makes you get up out of bed
at 6:00 AM to,
you know,
do some work before my little boy gets up to get ready.
You know,
it's,
it's the drive.
Um,
I just want to do that.
I guess there's a problem that you thought,
right.
I can fix this.
Um,
to me it seems like the big difference in entrepreneurship today compared to say
like 30 years ago is the need to monetize and,
and where that comes in.
So I just wonder,
it's when you started thinking about that and,
and what pressure you got from funds about how developed your thinking had to
be.
Yup.
Um,
there was an amazing,
um,
uh,
deck for the linkedin series B race.
Um,
I think it's on the gray lock website anyway.
If,
if you haven't read it,
you should go and have a look at it.
Cause it's amazing because it's actually a critique by one of the cofounders of
his own deck as a like looking at it from a VC perspective,
having been the entrepreneur and in that he kind of identifies three lines of
possible revenue.
And his critique is,
you shouldn't be talking about three lines of revenue should really be only be
talking about one and but we didn't really know.
And you know,
so it's really interesting to see his kind of own critique of his own work
effectively.
Um,
and it's also,
I mean read it anyway cause it's really fascinating to see like what their
predicted growth was,
where they were and you forget,
I think we forget like how,
not how slow,
but it was an incremental growth.
It wasn't all of a sudden just bang Linkedin,
you know,
it took time.
Um,
so obviously I had thoughts and ideas on monetization.
I've come from a world where,
you know,
Purdue monetized extreme and monetizers extremely well.
And um,
so I had ideas.
Um,
I think probably my main stress point,
and it's,
I think it's specific to my market is everyone assumes I want to do advertising.
It's women,
they're moms advertising.
Is that your model?
No,
absolutely not.
You know,
it's that.
So for me it was more about here are some other,
I like possible streams.
I don't know which ones are right cause I need to see how people are engaging
with the product before I can definitively say,
but here's some ideas and no,
not all of them revolve around an ad model.
Um,
but I think having
some smart thought around how you could see it progressing even if it doesn't
end up going that way,
but to show that you've given it consideration,
it's a good idea.
Um,
but you know,
linkedin started with three strings on their deck is good enough for them.
I think we had time for them.
One more crispier.
Okay,
good.
Hi Em.
Supply at a time you launched mustard also just launched something.
How you handled that and your investor presentations and they start was a kind
of pushback from potential investors at all.
Um,
I think that any,
anyone who is doing something in the same space as you or the same market as
you,
it is,
um,
confidence that there is a market and all it does,
you know,
there wasn't just one dating app.
Um,
there isn't just one type of cola drink.
there was probably just one search engine,
but,
uh,
um,
but you know,
I think all of those,
um,
having the ability to have um,
someone else in the market,
um,
just as a establishes a,
a proof of the validity in the market.
And I think that's important.
Um,
I think that what's,
what will be your differentiator is how you execute,
how you see the market evolving,
how you see your product devolving,
how you see differentiators.
Um,
and there for me there are just lots of different ways to solve the same problem
and it's all about how your,
your answering that problem and what,
why you're the right person to solve the problem that in the way that you see
it.
Cause everyone will,
will take a different approach.
Um,
so in terms of how I responded to it,
didn't really,
or not,
and what we were doing.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I think we've run out of time,
so I'm going to thank Michelle for joining us.
It was amazing.
Thank you so much for coming in and let's get her a round of applause.
[inaudible].